[Musique]
comme la sensation d'être noise haut au
dessus de ce bijou architectural
l'expérience ne laisse personne
indifférent
au centre le château un chantier
pharaonique d'une image du paradis bâtie
par les mains de l'homme la séance dure
12 minutes
passée trop vite pour cette mère et sa
fille on est tellement ébloui par les
images qu'on veut tout voir le château
de champs bas et une telle merveille que
forcément on essaye de deux d'aller
regarder tout ce qu'on peut voir capter
et
là c'est vrai que ses angles de vue
permettent de s'approcher de choses
qu'on peut avoir normalement quoi
commencent à survoler
des paysages il ça fait un peu peur au
début je me dis ah je vais tomber les
confinements ont permis de filmer
chambord sans ses visiteurs habituels il
aura fallu au total un an et demi aux
producteurs pour réaliser ce court
métrage car pour retracer les origines
du château il a fallu aller jusqu'en
italie
regarder des documentaires ce qui se
faisait et
dans ce que j'avais pu voir je n'avais
pas d'information sur ce qui précède et
chambord et j'ai eu envie du coup de
comprendre d'où venait le souffle d'où
venait l'idée d'où ses voyages en italie
source de la renaissance et ce mariage
entre ces deux pays
le film sortira au cinéma et dans les
ehpad en espérant que les spectateurs
n'auront pas trop le vertige